[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
joining us on the line is professor
brian keating cosmologist at the
university of california san diego which
means he studies the stars he's not a
cosmetologist which is like the person
who does makeup he's also the author of
the best-selling memoir losing the nobel
prize his latest book is his newest book
think like a nobel prize winner brian
thanks so much for joining the show
great to talk to you
yeah it's good to see you again ben so
let's talk about this
amazing stuff that we're getting now
from the webb telescope so first of all
what is the web telescope and why should
we care other than it makes pretty
pictures
well it does a lot more than that it's
uh it's a 10 billion dollar investment
probably the most complicated object
human beings have ever shot off into
space and it's located a million miles
away from earth it's actually four times
the distance to the moon and its job is
really to peer back almost to the
beginning of time not quite to the
beginning of time that's my that's my
domain they're not allowed to go back
all the way to the beginning but they're
allowed to look at and their goal is to
look at the earliest structures that
ever formed in the universe that's one
major topic to look at galaxies the
first stars that form to see if the
edifice on which all of modern science
stands upon which is which is based on
our origin of the universe if there is
good solid framework for it and also in
so doing these these photons these
particles of light traverse the universe
and they encode the properties of the
universe as it's evolved since the
origin of time including relatively
nearby objects by our standards things
that are only a few thousand light years
away and those are called exoplanets
those are other planets perhaps just
like the earth that could potentially
harbor forms of life and uh and that and
that's a you know what if they have a
you know competitor podcast to to you
ben so we want to make sure that
everyone out there is uh fully apprised
of all the latest happenings so this
telescope is really a culmination of
decades of work it's way over budget way
over time but it really does what
nothing else can do which is which is to
peer back and give us a glimpse into our
cosmic origins so brian i watched a
video where you were talking about this
telescope and obviously you've spent
your life making telescopes and and
monitoring telescopes so the what what
amount of complexity went into this and
also i mean how high was the risk here
because this is out in the middle of
nowhere if something is broken on this
thing you're basically screwed and you
just sent 10 billion dollars worth of
hardware
in into into just space for no reason
yeah exactly yeah this this had so many
what we call single point failure risks
where any one
individual problem could compromise the
whole 10 billion dollar mission whether
that could be blowing up on the launch
pad or not being able this telescope is
so big and so wide it could not be
launched in its final configuration and
had to be unfolded uh and unpacked like
origami and i have some animations on my
youtube channel of that process and that
is a technological hurdle not just
because you're building something in
space with no astronauts nearby to
service it as you said it's a it's it's
uh you know thousands of times farther
away than the hubble the hubble space
telescope is actually closer to us than
than you and i are right now and in
other words the hubble space is only 250
miles above the earth this is you know
this is a million miles away so no
chance of repair no no no service
stations out there in space and so this
how to work they had to work it had to
work the right time the first time and
with no opportunity for repair so uh and
it also had to be unfolded and the
mirrors aligned to a precision less than
the diameter of a human hair and so that
uh that is just astounding
accomplishment and there were many times
when it could have been canceled and it
could have been um and and some
astronomers rightfully i have to you
know mention it some astronomers didn't
think they should continue with it
because it did kind of swallow nasa's
budget but now that it's out there you
know you forgot about the the birthing
pains of of the of the baby and now it's
doing this phenomenal science as of as
of just this week so what is the the
sort of program for the telescope how
long is it supposed to sit out there
before it it is out of range or degrades
or does it sort of stay in like how does
it stay out there how do we communicate
with it and and what do we expect to get
from it in terms of data
yeah so it's pretty amazing it's not
orbiting like the moon orbits around the
the earth and the earth orbits around
the sun this object is orbiting around a
blank piece of space it's basically
trailing behind the sun uh earth and
moon by a distance of as i said a
million miles away from the earth so
it's it's kind of this amazing uh point
in space called the lagrange point for
you aficionados out there i know your
audience is the second smartest in the
universe except for my audience uh and
this this object has to maintain that
precision called station keeping for
hopefully two decades or more there's
really almost no limitation on its
lifetime it's shielded from the brutal
conditions of space by this very thin
mylar balloon-like material and that
blocks enough light and heat that it can
remain cold these cameras are not seeing
light like you and i are looking at each
other right now they're seeing infrared
radiation which is slightly longer
wavelength which is not visible to the
human eye so it's revealing things that
hubble could not see and it will do so
for two decades so
you've obviously had you know a rich
amount of time to study these photos i
mean you've had you've had all of like
24 hours to look at these photos so
explain the secrets of the universe so
what exactly has been confirmed here i
mean obviously they've talked about the
the curvature of space-time and and the
and the
sort of confirmation of einsteinian
theories of relativity um but what are
some of the earliest things that we've
learned
yeah it's interesting so yeah of course
the data just came out a few hours ago
when the time we're talking but but we
kind of had a hint at what they would be
looking at and of course hubble's been
up for a long for 30 years now and so it
was able to you know kind of provide a
finderscope view of what these objects
would look like again different
wavelengths different signs so what
these five images that they released
really do portend for the future of this
of this mission uh is quite astounding
uh we'll be able to look at the effects
of gravity on distant objects and
gravity is the most pervasive force in
the universe it's the one i use as an
excuse why i don't go to the gym for the
last 30 years but this uh but gravity is
the most dominant force and yet it's the
weakest force you don't think about that
when you're at the gym pumping iron but
uh but it's actually the weakest force
so therefore it can have the longest
range it can reach out across the
entirety of the universe and affect the
properties of massive clusters and stars
and what we're most interested in i
think with web are really two or three
different main topics one is the effects
on the early universe how did the early
universe assemble the star which came
first the star or the galaxy in other
words how do we know what the elemental
building blocks are of astronomy we
actually don't have a great idea for
that what is the nature of dark matter
and dark energy dark matter and dark
energy then make up 95 percent of the
universe's mass and energy and we have
no clue whatsoever what they are and and
then the third thing that many people
are are really interested in and i i
kind of aped you and and did a brian
keating reacts video uh you know there
was less you know woke tears and there
weren't so many libs of tick-tock on it
but uh but nevertheless i did a reaction
to what i'm most interested in is the
search for life in the universe because
i'm actually a life uh a pessimist i
don't believe that there's life
elsewhere in the universe but no one
would be more thrilled than i to
discover that there is life in the
universe and what what webb can do and
when it releases just a tantalizing hint
of an object that we know doesn't have
life on it uh it's it's an object you
know something like half the size of
jupiter the planet jupiter
and it's cruising around a star every
three days so it's getting pretty toasty
a little toastier than than down there
in florida but uh but the object has
some strong atmospheric lines that it
can actually demonstrate the properties
of water and many scientists think that
water is a necessary
ingredient not sufficient but necessary
ingredient for life to be supported
again i'm not so sanguine that there is
life in the universe there's zero
evidence for life elsewhere in the
universe but that would make me the most
surprised and excited to find out that
it's true and so web has this unique
ability that even my powerful telescopes
that my colleagues and i are building we
have no ability to do that so web is
unique in that sense well that's brian
keating he of course is the author of
losing the nobel prize and his latest
book is think like a nobel prize winner
brian thanks so much for the insight on
this stuff it really is amazing and
fascinating and if you're a religious
person it confirms your belief that
there's a god in the universe if you're
not religious then you know science is
cool brian really appreciate the time
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]